[Musique]
en solo mais collectionneurs
d'équipement cinématographique
injecteurs fort 1 2906 avant les salles
de cinéma avec sa lanterne rouge
la collection comprend environ 2008 m
sans compter les films un millier vous
avez visionné stéréo et lanternes nager
des caméras du début du cinéma de ce
qu'on appelle le cinéma des premiers
temps on va dire 1895 à 1930 il ya eu
environ 35000 caméras appareils photos
qui ont été fabriqués de tous les temps
et de tous les pays alors qui a que 10 %
de sable devrait 3000 3500 qui ont été
fabriqués en caméra avant si des caméras
et projecteurs
je vais lever un peu dans une famille de
photographes les mariages les
enterrements les baptêmes j'ai fait ça
étant petit d'autre part il ya déjà 50
ans dans une petite caméra super-8 je
vais mal à natashquan filmer les parents
de gilles vigneault
imaginez vous
j'ai en fait commencé à collectionner au
début des années 2000 parce qu'on peut
les caméras de films commencé à être
désuet depuis que vous aviez le
numérique qui arrivait
dû commencer en acheter une est acheté 2
et puis quand on commence à
collectionner bien alors on devient
curieux
il a à ce moment là yb est arrivé sur le
marché et après j'ai commencé à chercher
des appareils anciens est venu les
appreils de russie de tchécoslovaquie de
france beaucoup des états unis
jacky ce presbytère parce que je
trouvais que c'était un lieu idéal pour
faire un musée j'ai réalisé que ce
serait trop complexe et trop coûteux
[Musique]
sud et si vite se sent mieux de vendre
la collection ou de la donner
j'aurais pu la vendre à la chine
j'aurais pu lavande à dubaï
j'avais aussi des contacts mais je
voulais que cette collection reste au
québec
j'ai pris une entente avec l'université
laval pour faire le don de l'entièreté
de ma collection qui va servir à des
recherches pour les étudiants
internationaux et également à des
futures expositions et des futurs color
alors le plus cocasse ce que c'est pas
parce que j'ai données que j'arrête
d'acheter un pas du tout est ce qu'en
passé c'est sûr j'ai une fierté de ça et
en plus la collection porte mon nom moi
qui ai pas eu d'enfant au moins j'avais
quelque chose à la société
[Musique]